hello everyone tomorrow is the start of
the London chess classic but before that
today is something called the London
chess classic probe is cup it's an event
where eight professional chess players
are teamed up with eight amateur chess
players businessmen and the event will
last for three rounds its rapid games
will be played 20 minutes for the entire
game and the five-second increment per
move and after the three rounds a winner
will be proclaimed it's very interesting
how the organizers decided to settle
things if there will be a tie after
three rounds if there will be a tie
after three rounds of blitz then the
amateurs from each team will play a
blitz game and if that game ends in a
draw then from the two top teams the
grandmasters will play against amateurs
and whichever grandmaster checkmates the
amateur before the other grandmaster
death team will be proclaimed the winner
so a very interesting event and I will
tell you the results of the event after
I show you the game this is the game
Magnus Carlsen versus Garry Kasparov a
very very nice pairing especially since
today is still Carlson's birthday
Carlson was paired with Chris flowers
and Garry Kasparov was teamed with teri
Chapman I have no idea who these people
are obviously there are businessmen
but well let's see the game and it's
very it's not always if you've ever
played to hunt to chess it's not always
best to play the best move if if your
teammate is a weaker player then you'd
have to play a move that he will
understand so he can follow you so it's
it's a very you know not not gonna be
easy
neither for call senator for Kasparov so
Carlson and mr. flowers have the white
pieces Carlson opens up with E for and
on every board the professional chess
players are playing the first move so
Carlsen opens with E 4 and we have C 6
by Kasparov the caro-kann defense Chris
plays d4 and Terry responds with the d5
we have Knights to D to the modern
variation by Carlson but Kasparov goes
straight into the
classic line with the D characters on e4
we have night captures on d4 by Chris
and the bishop to f5 by Terry and here
there are a lot of moves possible
the most common move is night to g3 with
a temple and the bishop and this will be
continuing with something like maybe
Bishop g6 and h4 you've seen this plenty
of times already but aside from this
night to g3 move you can either play
Bishop b3
you can even retreat the Knight to c3
but Crosse central draws a very
interesting approach you played Queen to
f3 and I haven't seen Queen Queen f3
ever in this variation so very
interesting cuz pearl responds with a 6
we have C 3 by Chris and the Knight to
d7 by Terry Bishop to f4 by Carlsen
Queen to b6 by Kasparov now eyeing that
B to pawn and Bishop to d3 by Chris it's
interesting Chris didn't didn't decide
to defend this B to pawn he left it for
capture and also he didn't decide to go
for this Knight to d6 check it does seem
like it's you're attacking the king it
would check you're attacking the bishop
on f5 and it's interesting that he
didn't go for this to grab this dark
square bishop but this would actually
favor black if Bishop captures Bishop
captures then Queen captures on b2
attacking the rook and after rook to d1
Knight to f6 this night is coming to e4
and if you if you play a bad move with
white of course Bishop to g4 is also an
idea so we don't have to block that
something like Knight to e2 but now
Bishop to C 2 again attacking the rook
and have to route to c1 which is the
only moon 94 and the white is white it's
it's very annoying to play this position
with white it's pretty much you can't
move any piece you can't move the knight
you're gonna lose the rook you can
develop the bishop you can't castle your
bishop on d6 is attacked so I don't know
if I don't know if Chris knew this but
nevertheless after Queen
six he played Bishop to d3 we have
Bishop captures on e4 now and also an
interesting move by Carrie if he decided
to go for something like Queen captures
on b2 now I don't have to look to be one
Bishop captures on e4 and now Bishop
captures on e4 so the queen is
predicting the c3 pawn and the bishop is
protecting the rook and be one Queen
captures on a two and now if you
recapture some b7 sure black is up a
piece but wife has tremendous
development and white is definitely
better here but okay seems like both the
Chris and Terry are no amateurs here
after Bishop to d3 Terry responded with
Bishop captures on e4
we have Bishop captures on e4 and Knight
G to f6 Knight to e2 and now Knight
captures on e4 by Terry Carlsen
recaptures Queen captures on e4 and we
have Bishop to e7 Chris castles theory
castles and the Queen to c2 by Carlsen
now Carson wants to defend this pawn you
know when you're when you're playing at
the two on two chests you you don't want
to be down upon you don't know if your
colleague will be able to use all this
activity so rook F to e8 my Kasparov now
rook F to e 1 by Chris c5 by Terry and
rook a to D 1 by Carlsen rook a to D 8
by Kasparov and now d5 we have each
chapter 75 recapture Sundy file and
Queen to e6
casparo attacks the rook on d5 we have
rook e to D 1 by Chris now Chris doubles
up on the D file and Knight to f6 now I
would attempt on the rook also offering
an exchange of ropes here we have rook
captures and e8 my Carlson and the
bishop captures on the 8th bike as part
of rook captures on the 8th was also an
option and here we have a move Knight to
g3 and this is a very interesting move
that Chris made as the rook and the
Queen are attacking the knight this
might be why Kasparov played Bishop
capture son d8 and
Chris was worried about this you know
your night is attacked
if you move the night you get Queen to
e1 and this leads to checkmate
so keep late nights the g3 now Queen e1
doesn't work okay Knight to f1 is still
a defensive resource but here's what
Christmas
Queeny 6 or is attacking the knight and
e2 but also is attacking the a to pawn
and here Christmas that he had the c-4
move now now you're blocking the Queen's
attack to DA to pawn and the thing is
the Queen can't capture the night if
Queen captures night on e2 then simply
Queen captures Queen and if you capture
the Queen Bishop rook captures Bishop on
the 8th you retreat with the rook you
exchange works and Knight captures any
eight and now Bishop to b8 both the a7
ponen the c5 pawn are on a dark square
and after a couple more defensive moves
Bishop a7 going for the c5 pawn a 96
attacking the c4 pawn b3 defending and
after Knight 3 for defending the c5 pawn
the King comes into the game and after
f6 kinky one and something like f3
you're kicking away tonight from the
defense of the c5 pawn okay this does
seem like it's a lot of moves but it's
not something we have to calculate this
is this is known so okay after Bishop
Bishop captures on b8 night the g3 a
Christmas the c-4 idea and now we have
Queen captures on a2 by Terry and I'm
sure cuz para was very happy to see this
that Terry grabbed the pawn and now they
are pawn up and in a better position
Knight to f5 by Carlson and Kasparov
retreats Queen to e6
we have h3 by Chris making some
breathing room for the King a good
decision Knight to e4 by Terry and now
Queen to f4 by Carlsen a sneaky move
Carson is still trying to do something
he's attacking the a7 pawn
also eyeing that row Kenny 8 so Queen
captures night and f5 isn't possible
because of Queen captures rook on eh
checkmate sokka's power plays Bishop 2
six now he decides to defend the a
7-point Queen to d7 now by Chris
offering an exchange of Queens and now a
powerful move by Terry Terry please see
for and it's a it's a great decision it
locks down this B to pawn and b2 it can
go forward and also it opens up the
attack from this Bishop to the f2 point
as the knight is attacking it as well so
a very nice decision Bishop to e3 by
Carlson and night the c5 by Kasparov
Queen captures now on e6 by Chris F
captures on e6 with a temple on the
night we have Bishop captures and c5 by
crossing Bishop characters by Kasparov
and this is okay it's it's a better
position for black black is up a pawn
and he does have a bishop against a
knight probably also he has three points
to two points on the Queen side
all in all a better position for black
definitely but it's still playable for
white white white can still you know try
to try to get something out of the
position but unfortunately in this
position Chris blunders the game away
for him and for Carlsen he plays Knight
to d6 attacking the rook on e8 also the
pawn on c4 hoping to win a pawn and if
not at least exchanged night for a
bishop and a rock ending being upon up
isn't that bad actually
but unfortunately he missed the smooth
and Terry finds it of course Terry plays
rook to d8 and in this position both
Carson and Chris flowers resigned the
game as there is no defense from rook
captures night if you move the night you
get rook captures rook on d1 so you lose
the piece at least so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it you know I
was very happy to see that Carson got to
play Gary Kasparov although you know he
did lose against him on his birthday but
what are you gonna do and the one other
interesting thing all the teams had like
two timeouts you could you could call
two timeouts
in one minute and you could you know
talk about the position with your
colleague and explain some things to him
so yeah that's the game how'd you like
it and I'm interested what do you think
who is the better player here
Chris flowers or teri Chapman I'm kind
of going with dairy because he did
choose a couple of pretty good moves
during the game as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here think all
for watching and I will see you soon